povid cases continue to surge here  locally and all across the nation  as we get deeper into winter and wait  for the first doses of the long-awaited  cova vaccine  let's take a look at our local numbers  here in nevada we are now reporting a 21  positivity rate over the last two weeks  more than 2500 new cases were also  reported  bringing the overall total to more than  168 thousand  fourteen new deaths were also added the  death toll now stands  at just over three hundred clark county  does account for the majority of state  cases  we have more than one hundred and twenty  seven thousand here locally and more  than eighteen hundred people have died  the recovery rate is just above eighty  four percent